une aussi brillante intervention je ne
sais quoi dire d'autre je me sens
intimidée où on va essayer de relever le
défi
alors le thème de mon intervention
aujourd'hui c'est le film avatar ma
fierté je suis prisca kouakou passionnés
la communication des nouvelles
technologies et de tout ce qui se
rapporte au développement personnel
les conférences ted et mois avant la
même histoire nous sommes nés dans la
même année
1984 est le fondateur et chasseurs rural
les prénoms de deux personnes qui me
sont chers donc un sol qui correspond
également à paul le prénom de mon père
et richard lepeu nom de mon père adoptif
donc je suis ici je suis chez moi
alors comme je disais ton temps j'ai 30
ans et je suis heureux d'avoir pu à
terme tous les objectifs que je m'étais
fixé pour ses trente années de vie à
savoir fonder une famille heureuse
elle mais d'autres enfants travailler
dans ce domaine que j'aime que la
communication crier nos ong ou des
monnaies de fille est scolarisée et là
aujourd'hui ou partager avec vous cette
fabuleuse expérience de ma vie
alors pour commencer
je dirais que je suis une femme at il
donc ils voient bien à dire et donc je
jamais que des événements tragiques de
ma vie et je souhaiterais d aborder avec
vous c'est pas facile de pouvoir
s'ouvrir parler aujourd'hui parce qu'on
a vécu et je
suis fier comme je le disais d'avoir pu
atteindre ses objectifs parce que quand
je regarde en arrière tout ceci était
pas gagné d avance
on va faire et ma mère quand j'ai vu ma
soeur et moi à la dure tout ce qui est
en grève pékin a effectué un aller je me
suis beaucoup passer la brosse et des
parts contre légion
alors cet environnement n'a pas favorisé
en moins par piqué et joyeux j'étais
timide j'avais peur de me rapprocher des
autres parce que j'estime être tout le
monde était supérieur à moi et c'est
dans ce contexte où je cherchais encore
à trouver ma voie j'ai perdu mon père à
un mois de mai 18 ans
alors serait plutôt difficile pour ma
mère ma soeur et moi dans une somme que
deux filles et se fait d'autant plus
difficile que le renommé du décès de mon
père
saison que ses aînés sont venus à la
maison nous y ait de tous estimant que
parce que papa n'avait pas eu le garçon
c'était à eux que je venais c'est bien
et donc dû jouer le domaine de se
retrouver sans rien donc c'est une
réalité que beaucoup de familles vivent
en côte d'ivoire et dont on a toujours
parlé c'est une réalité et je dirais
même j'avais des pneus ou même les
quatre vainqueurs de leur père n'a pas
échappé à ses troisièmes alors on trois
repas par jour nous sommes passés à un
repas par jour je dirais vive le régime
à 500 calories et toc c'est dans cet
environnement que je devais passer le
baccalauréat
le père fut inhumé le week-end qui a
précédé les épreuves écrites du
baccalauréat au village même pendant les
obsèques certaines personnes avaient
déjà accepté mon échec à ma place ces
personnes me disent écoute puisqu'un si
tu ne réussis pas cette année c'est pas
grave avec tout ce que j'ai traversé
comme épreuve autoportant est ce que ces
personnes ne savaient pas c'est que moi
j'avais compris que mon père avait fini
sa vie et que c'était maintenant la
mienne qui commençait donc armé de toute
la fois que j'avais un dieu le tout les
conseils de ma mère je peux obtenir le
baccalauréat au lit mais j'ai été je
dirais pas bizarrement mais dans le
quartier d'un seul avoir réussi son bac
alors les défis qui se présentaient à
voir c'était de même si le baccalauréat
poursuis mes études et pouvoir réussir
ma vie alors depuis cette victoire je
n'ai cessé de me battre aller aussi loin
dans les études que le maître moyenne
lui permettaient alors devant deux
accessoires de cheveux avant d ofi péri
j'ai multiplié les petits boulots pourra
subvenir à mes besoins je mets mon la
demande et de n'être personne loin
pouvoir financer la formation supérieure
et de tous est ce que je retiens je
retiens trois leçons ce que fait de
pouvoir faire et nous tondre il faut
aller de l'avant et ça c'est une
citation de markopoulo aussi que celui
qui convainc peut-être mais celui qui ne
combat pas a déjà perdu la bataille en
fait celui qui ne laisse pas la réalité
des dangers ses rêves est un singe et
donc face à toute cette situation
maintenant que je vivais ces difficultés
là je ne sais c'est de penser à toutes
ces filles orphelines qui comme moi
n'avaient pas peut-être ce courage là de
se battre ou affronter la vie se bat
voire plus si le rêve est en plus assez
jeune fille j'ai décidé que lorsque
j'aurai du travail je vais crier nos lgv
n'est monette aux filles déscolarisées
et c'est ce que je fais en 2012 en
clients légers et fifem éducation
formation et sociaux pour les femmes
notre mission est d'offrir aux jeunes
filles déscolarisées non scolarisés de
meilleures perspectives d'avenir à
travers une formation et une éducation
de qualité
et donc nous venons plusieurs activités
dont l'alphabétisation en france moins
de capacités en lecture et écriture
la formation professionnelle donc
lorsqu'elle donne à paul lacouture
l'apathie série également le soutien
psychologique parce que nous échangeons
avec un nomade en compte que ces jeunes
filles qui pour la plupart sont fille de
ménage non pas une certaine ont une
certaine image d'elle qui dépendait donc
nous partageons je partage avec elle mon
expérience d'un feeling également afin
que cette fille là puissent reprendre
confiance en elles me font confiance à
la vie ou construire l avenir meilleur
alors j'en rêve on peut mieux ce concept
ce qu'il y ait plus de femmes
analphabètes en côte d'ivoire une fille
est scolarisée
on peut aussi voir ce que toutes ces
filles qu'on appelle aujourd'hui
déscolarisés et vient de mes des femmes
d'entreprise les femmes leaders de ce
pays je crois que nous pouvons y arriver
donc facile le contact et je vous
laisserai avec cette citation cette
pensée que je vous invite à méditer ce
que la souffrance peut nous freiner mais
elle n'est pas une excuse ne pas réussir
nos vies je vous remercie